One of the problems people have with
electric cars is charging time.
Yes, modern fast chargers can get
your car to 80% in about half an hour,
maybe even a little quicker
if you're lucky,
but that's a long time compared
to the three or four minutes
that it takes to fill up
with petrol or diesel.
So when I first heard there
was a car company
building automated
battery swap stations,
where robots will switch out
your car battery
in just a few minutes,
while you stay in the car...
I assumed it'd be
a weird prototype,
some pie-in-the-sky technology
from a university
that would never become practical.
But that is a
battery swap station,
right there,
open to the public,
so let's see if it works.
- Nio has more than 2,100 stations
operational in China,
and the goal is to reach 2,300
by end of year.
In Europe, we started around
two years ago,
and we have now 30
operational stations.
In China, every day we have more than
40,000 battery swaps being performed,
one every two seconds.
And we have had peaks during
holiday season,
more than 60,000 a day.
We're not just piloting this,
it's already proven at scale.
- As ever, this is not an advert,
they haven't paid me,
I reached out to them,
they have just let me borrow a car.
[Car] "Please press the brake pedal."
"Nicely done!"
"Now you can tap to start parking
into the Power Swap station."
- You drive the car
in front of the station,
and once you park
the car takes over.
And it's fully automatic.
[Car] "We are parking now."
"Be aware of your surroundings."
"Do not open any door or
take over the steering wheel."
"You can press the brake panel
to control the speed."
- Nio users, if they want to access
the Power Swap network,
they need to choose
"Battery as a Service".
So that means they don't
own the battery,
they lease the battery,
and so they can get access to
the Power Swap station network.
You can purchase
the battery and the car.
Or you can purchase the car,
but choose access
to the swapping network.
You can also just subscribe to
both the car and the battery.
- The idea is that you're not renting
or buying a specific battery,
but you're just paying for there always
being a fresh battery in your car.
Charging is still a cheaper option,
but there are plenty of people
who'll pay a fee for convenience.
[Car] "Preparing. Please wait."
- We can serve the same amount of
users comparable to a charging hub,
but we need only one third of the space
and we need one third of
the grid connection
because we can charge the
batteries at their low speed.
We provide frequency balancing services.
We charge the batteries
at specific points in time
where there is a need to get rid of
all that power and balance the grid.
- The thing is, I've driven
electric cars on long trips before,
and charging wasn't
really a big problem:
it needs a little more planning
than using fossil fuels,
but turns out, I want to rest
at about the same interval
the car wants charging.
Folks out there who can drive
eight hours in one go...
good luck, but I am not one of you.
- The best way to charge a vehicle
is at home if you have a socket, right?
With EV becoming more affordable,
there are more people who want
to access an electric vehicle,
and don't have the opportunity
to have a socket close to
where they park their car.
Shanghai, a city with more
than 20 million inhabitants,
people live in big apartments,
and so, on-street charging,
it's much less than in Europe.
People don't have access to home charging
because it's a much more dense city.
Power Swap offers a great opportunity
to just leave your home,
drive to the station,
swap your battery
and continue your trip.
- And of course, there is the catch
that this battery swap station
only works for cars that
are built for it.
You can get a Nio battery
swapped here,
but there's no other car on
the market that can use this.
At least, not yet.
- We have been signing strategic agreements
with big groups like Changan and Geely Group.
We have gained the confidence
of also the other auto makers.
There's a opportunity to
standardize this technology,
in China, but perhaps
also in Europe.
We're going to invest
in Battery as a Service.
And we're going to invest
in the Power Swap network.
If you take the whole economics,
we do believe that this is better
than just selling a car.
- Plenty of people,
electric vehicle enthusiasts,
stock brokers,
people who've bought Nio stock,
have a running analyses on whether the
company's financial model will work.
Building these stations is
incredibly expensive,
and it's no secret that Nio is losing
a staggering amount of money right now,
but that's the way that
colossal startup companies
and finance work these days.
They hope the initial outlay
will be worth it in the end.
That strategy has paid off
for a lot of big corporations...
and not paid off for many more.
I looked at a lot of those
financial analyses
while I was researching
and my conclusion is:
I don't know!
Predicting anything about electric vehicles
is almost impossible:
it's an industry filled with both
radical inventions and broken promises.
I'm just astonished that something
I thought was science fiction
does appear to be an actual
real-world option right now...
and that a robot just
swapped out my car battery.